Hi. I figured I'd come back
for let's say another hour and a
half and uh we will just keep on going
with this
refactor. We'll see how much progress we
make.
I was expecting to spend all day
tomorrow on this, but you know, maybe we
uh we get a little farther than that and
we'll actually be able to start
evaluating like the new features and
things on the experiment side and we'll
have most of the cleanup done either
tonight or by pretty early
tomorrow. That would be a pretty good
outcome. Believe we had it working.
No, we did not. What was I doing right
before I
left? Bosses,
right? Boss's items.
We can just add a dummy for
that. No biggie.
Didn't we have losses up
here? Ah, so we have self losses.
um we'll move that a little bit. Right.
We'll just do this as losses.
This. Okay. Okay. And then the next
little piece
here. We have to update this which is a
little annoying. We do get to get rid of
this zeroing
lines. Good.
So that runs
seems like it does for
now. So we can add that back
in and then generally I guess we just
start going through
uh we start going through the train
function. So P3 is the big one that
we're not doing just yet.
Um, compute puff
advantage takes a lot of
this. So train
copy and then you call
sample train misk
It's a little
silly. Listen to
logits. Then we go to train
misk. We have
Diane we're still looking at. We've got
some reshape
logic experience. We need to experiment
with
this. Do this if we are KL
clipping. Okay. So there is some KL
stuff to be saved potentially.
advantage. We have to recomputee
trajectory segments.
Why do we have to recmp compute
trajectory
I'm just going to go through and label
stuff like this because, you know, it's
a bit late for me to be really thinking
about things like this. But,
um, I can at least like
start. I say it's late at 700 p.m., but
hey, I go to bed before 10.
replay and then you get your policy
loss. This is clean RL.
All clean
RL. I think we're going to want clipped
losses like always pretty
this gradient variance wasn't
particularly useful.
it. I can just do losses of gradient
variance, right?
Nice. Is this screwed up because the
gradients are already
averaged? That might be screwed up
because gradients are already averaged.
We're gonna get rid of this for
now. Okay. And then we have the KL
target, which we don't
use. It seems like we probably should
consider using it.
Maybe and then rep prioritize experience
happens at the end
here. Max uses, mean
uses. We may or may not need
batches. Ah, and actually I think that
we need to
um don't
we? Yeah, these losses can get tabbed
in, can't
in. And then at the bottom
here, maybe a few small
things, a few small things to uh
modify, but really not very
So the main things that I see whether we
keep off policy at
all that seems more speculative for
future
stuff. Maybe it doesn't have to be in
this
version. Rep prioritization. Maybe I can
figure that out right now. You know,
maybe I can figure out rep
prioritization. So, what's you know what
is going on here?
right? I think it was the importance
ratio.
right? Okay. So, you say that you get
this new
ratio.
Um, I'm confused as to why this this
changed. It's new log prop minus batch
log props, right?
watched your videos on puffer liib and
if I recall puffer liib is like a data
pipeline from RL environments to models
to really streamline RL we do a lot of
stuff uh we have ultraast reinforcement
learning environments for testing and
research and also for iterative
prototyping in industry we have very
nice low-level tools like fast
multiprocessing fast vectorization
um we've got like this native way to to
that makes it really easy to develop
reinforcement learning libraries in C or
reinforcement learning environments in C
and make them very very fast. Uh we have
a very high performance very low
overhead trainer that is quite simple to
use. We have integrations with optimizer
enhancements, advantage filtering, new
little algorithmic tidbits. So really I
mean this is a comprehensive effort to
just make reinforcement learning sane,
simple and easy.
Oh, it's because um you only get Hang
on. You only get
updates on the samples that you run,
right?
Okay. Okay. Wow, that's a lot. Feels
like it should be focused for every RL
library and
framework. Training as fast as possible
and data efficient as possible. I
honestly the rest of RL is just trolling
right now.
Like it's
been since it's been since like clean RL
since anybody's done anything reasonable
in this space.
Um we're going to change that and we are
changing it very quickly. I mean we now
have we have training running like
anywhere from 500,000 to 3 million steps
per second for reasonable policies. Uh
we can run tens of billions of
experiments per day on a single GPU. We
have a ton of different environments
that we use for research. We've got a
nice open source community of people
building stuff. Our code is way simpler
than libraries that are 100x slower. But
I mean really this is this is where I'm
placing my bet on making RL
work. It started off like yeah we're
going to build some low-level tools and
we're going to integrate with all the
other libraries and it's going to be
like you know just a small thing. But
now it's it's really we are going to fix
everything that's wrong with this
field. Like this train file has almost
zero
dependencies and uh it's currently
under400 lines for
everything. And we're going to try to
get this thing even shorter. But like my
goal would be to have something that's
close to a thousand lines that just
solves everything basically out of the
box. Few extra tidbits not included in
there mind you, but like that's all of
the algorithm. That's all like the
experience buffer. That's like pretty
much everything other than like models,
environments, and then I think there's
hyperparam sweep stuff that's outside of
this as well.
Yeah, the hyper pram stuff is probably
going to stay outside of here. Other
than that though, pretty
Did I not solve
this by moving the advantage computation
down something very odd about this.
So you need this
ratio know what to
sample. I don't like that I have like
two separate places where I have to do
all this advantage calculation stuff. I
mean I can make it much shorter but
still it's like confusing.
I'm computing the advantage on literally
everything here.
We're sampling based on
importance which is
advantages. And where's this
ratio variance
set. Yeah. So this is going to start out
as
one. I mean you ideally want this term
to be fresh because this is the vrace
part of our advantage
estimation. Really excited to try it.
amount of tedious work trying to write
different RL setups for each and every
different problem is incredibly annoying
and scales horribly. You really should
try some of this stuff out then like um
we got a nice community over on
discord.gg/puffer and you know the dev
branch is not going to be as stable as
the main branch but I will say that
we've pretty much just set soda on
everything we've thrown this at on dev
uh almost out of the box. It really it
feels like a different field.
uh on this code versus even on versus
like our 20 release like we have a
different Failed.
like here. This is an experiment that I
have running right
here. What are we
at? Okay, this is making some progress.
So, this x-axis is in tens of billions
of steps. So, this here is like 2,000
years worth of gameplay. And this is on
neural MMO 3. This is not a toym. This
is like way more interesting than the
vast majority of stuff in academia and a
lot of the stuff in industry. And you
can literally just go to Puffer AI and
play it right here. You can watch some
bots run around. You can like see
different agents doing stuff. They're
scripted agents, but they're also neural
like trained agents and they like buy
and sell stuff. They fight. They collect
resources. they get equipment and
stuff. And that's just one of our
benchmarks. And that environment runs at
uh 1.5 million steps per second on a
single CPU
core. So, I mean, it's just like orders
and orders of magnitude faster than
everything else out there. And you'd
think, oh, it must be really
complicated. But it's not. It's like
simpler than what's out there as well.
Is it all written in C? Just the
environments are in C environments. And
now we have like one CUDA extension for
one thing like an advantage function.
But uh the training code's all just
PyTorch. It's nicely optimized PyTorch.
Uh it's got really large batch sizes and
stuff like that to help it out. And
we've cut overhead in a number of
places. But yeah, the environments are
just in C. There's optimized
vectorization. The vectorzation's in
Python, but it's optimized so that like
everything writes into shared memory uh
without having to do a bunch of
redundant copies. And um I mean the M
code is actually very readable as well.
So like let's say you want to go play
around with neural MMO and like do
something with this environment or any
of the other ones that we have here in
the uh on the demo. I mean we have tons
of different things. Everything from
breakout up to that. Let's go here.
upper lib ocean's are first party first
party m and here's all the code 2800
some odd lines this is pretty much all
the code for neural mmo it's just one
file and if you just scroll through and
read this it's literally like first year
undergrad level C it's intentionally
very very
simple like if you've taken one systems
course like any course whatsoever taught
in C or C++ you can like read
Okay. So, it is actually necessary to
recmp compute the advantage the way I'm
doing it
because the policy is going to change
and then you have a new policy and then
you need this new ratio term.
sampling. To be fair, you could use a
different metric for sampling.
one that would be easier to
compute. But it makes sense to use the
advantage
function. This will get simpler though
if we get rid of the alternatives.
Like if it's just this, it'll just be
this one line.
Yeah. So, the like the main savings in
here, it's going to be
Okay, we can look at store next. Maybe
in a situation where I'd like to use RL
port, but I'm figuring out how much of
the codebase I'll need to rewrite and
see. So, you can technically write
Puffer M in Python. And uh we have cases
where we still train
like I think 100 to 200x faster than
other libraries even in Python.
Um, I mean the C is really nice, but
it's not necessarily
required. C++ and rewrote it in
JavaScript. I mean, if you can bind it
to Python, you can leave it like that.
Um, you can also do C++ to be honest. We
just in our M's, like the M's we ship
with Puffer Lib, we use C because I
don't like dealing with C++. But like
here, let me show you. You have two
options for this. The one that's in 20
right now is just we write a random Syon
intermediary. So like for something like
Pong, it's this little like binding
file. Not that little. It's 100 some odd
lines and it's just you have to redefine
the header basically. And then you have
this little init function that just
wraps the environment creation in Python
which then runs multiple copies of it
and it compiles to C. Uh and then in dev
the other option which is quite a bit
simpler is you just write a little
binding file like
this and you know you just say that okay
we're going to have functions like Cstep
C reset whatever you just follow like a
very basic little API and then you just
define a couple functions to tell you
how to convert arguments from Python to
C and then also what log data you want
to get back from C and then it's
And this just uses the Python C
API, which I believe should work fine
with uh with C++ as well. Like you can
mix and match if you want. We just we
choose not to because we don't like
dealing with C++ in our first party
ends.
have to rewrite some of the performance
critical
code in JavaScript in C or
C++. Well, it's really not going to be
that hard is what I'll say. Like with
the way we do stuff in Puffer, it's
really not that hard to write custom
M's and like you have a dozen different
environments that you can go read and
see how we've done
them. And you've got a helpful community
on uh on the Discord to help you out
when you get stuck. And you can always
bother me on stream with questions as
well because this is kind of why I
stream, right? Some people watch just
for like, ah, cool. Let's see what
programming is happening. but also that
we have people that watch to like come
drop by with questions about
puffer. So this is always going to be
the case now that I fix
this. So this is actually kind of
convenient, right?
We can always guarantee we have a
contiguous set. We can do
this. Ideally, we get it. So, we really
only support one major code path.
And it's just the best code
path. You know, I'd rather instead of
having like all toggleable features, I'd
rather just have one code path like one
feature set that is just the best
feature set.
Yeah. So, a few more things to fix up
over there for
That's like minus what 150 today with
all the new
good. I'm trying to think. I'd like to
keep doing some stuff for the next 45
minutes. I'm pretty tired though. I got
to find something simple I can work on
here. Let me see if anybody's bugging me
on Discord for
stuff. I had to just cancel that like
monthly
meeting. Nobody wants stuff for once
today. Cool.
That's like the one day I'd actually
uh looking for something simple to
do. Well, I'll just find something to
optimize
here. Why don't we get performance
numbers back
in? That would be good.
I think you literally have to add a dot.
Yeah, you have to add a dot items
obviously, right?
Let's do it this way. This is how I did
it before, right?
So now we have our profile numbers
back. We're missing
Yeah, you can't really even do this
here, can you?
I'm going to have to do that tomorrow.
I'm actually getting pretty
tired because I don't know how I want to
like restructure this right yet. But we
did get uh the
performance metrics back
on. Do we still solve breakout?
Or did I break something?
This is hardcoded for now. I got to make
an arc for that.
saving. Should still work,
right? That still works.
Okay. So, I guess they like just don't
have docks here anymore. So, I'm going
to have to migrate up.
Let's play with a couple things in the
meantime, right?
Let's just start on the thing I want us
to do in the morning tomorrow.
So um the first thing I wanted to do in
the morning was to
try like a value function
distribution kind of a deal
So the idea here is that you discretise
the uh the value
function. Yeah. The idea here is you
discretize the value function and then
you do cross entropy on
it instead of having to
do Oh shoot. But that's going to mess up
advantage completely, isn't
I'm trying to think how you would do
this.
They have a function for this in uh the
distributional Q-learning
paper or do they not have an advantage
function in here?
I guess we just do like some softmax
thing, right?
But it's
uh it's log of
softmax. It should just be soft max.
Uh, it got dark and I didn't bother to
turn the light
on. Hey,
bet. I actually Do I have a light here?
Yeah, I do.
Oh, that's real
bright. There we
go. We actually do have decent lighting,
huh? More, you
know. Uh, yeah, we got torched to work.
It was hell.
I'm messing around with some
distributional stuff at the moment.
went to the eye doctor and they were
critical of me never buying new
frames. Isn't that a Gandhi thing?
That's straight up a Gandhi thing right
there. You did
I'm kind of just hacking on this at the
moment to get something to
like something to work.
Okay. So now we can
do the loss function.
Oh, you're supposed to predict returns,
not
Yeah, it's bashes and he bashed his
keyboard.
advantage. Kind of have to redo it,
don't
You go right
here. Oh, no. You don't have to repeat
like any of this
actually cuz what you're going to do is
quite different. Okay, I think I get it.
So we do
I'm trying to think. Is there a better
way to do this?
Oh, wait. They gave me a formula for it,
didn't
they? They just do max minus
do? You just define a value max and a
value
And I'm kind of too tired to think about
how to do this right now. I think I'm
going to have to start fresh with the
proper formula of this. Basically, I
want to discretise the values uh into
buckets and have that nice play nicely
with the advantage
function. But I've been doing this all
day, so I'm going to start fresh in the
morning.
Um the point of this is just to see like
if there's anything there initially. If
it like if it instantly works then
great. you know, we'll know that we can
include something like that and then P30
is going to be probably not needed on
top of that.
Um, but yeah, I don't know. I'm
uh I'll be back all day
tomorrow. All my stuff's at
puffer.ai. If you want to help the
project out for free, start at the
GitHub. If you want to get involved with
dev, join the Discord,
discord.gg/puffer. If you'd like, you
can follow me on X for more RL content.
So, thanks and I will see you around.